hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to Sacramento now Sacramento
is a really interesting looking game and
I mean that quite literally I don't
usually judge games by it just its looks
alone this one in particular is so
fascinating because it blends together
2d styling in this really cartoonish and
jittery way in a 3d world I've never
played it before and I know this concept
is not new but the way that it's
presented itself is just so interesting
because it says that it's game about
exploration and discovery and again
that's not a new concept but I don't
know something about this game seems so
intriguing to me hello hi are you naked
am i bothering you why are you in this
purple forest don't by yourself I'm
sorry I'll just oh so sorry excuse me
I'll just move on then hi hello how are
you oh hi oh oh you're so pretty
oh hi excuse me excuse me
oh hi burbs oh hi burbs oh that's so
pretty
oh no you don't you don't want to go
that way it's Jeff over there okay all
right whoo excuse me I'm sorry pardon I
could just flatten them into the dirt
I'm sorry about that oh sorry oh it's so
weird but this is what I meant like it
it's this 2d like frame animation styled
it just leads it into this weird
combination of worlds that I've never
seen before
oh hi oh hi oh I'm guessing this is
where I'm supposed to go okay right
[Music]
hi oh that's so cool oh that's so cool I
have to sit oh no no don't take it away
from me
what I want to go back in oh come on
Oh what the hell you're gonna just let
me go in there and then take it all away
with the weird upward flowing water
through those leaves Oh what's happening
oh there's a lot more birds than there
were before oh no the Sun is setting I
don't like that oh I don't like that at
all I don't even know where I'm going
why is this Sun setting should it is
there something that I'm supposed to be
doing about that is there something to
be solved about it oh hello hi oh this
is new hello where are you leading me
where can i oh oh man I really gotta say
this is easily one of the most visually
striking indie games that I've played Oh
[Music]
hi fish how's it goin how are you doing
you oh hi fish oh hey hey hey hey hey
[Music]
what what well that's it well it can't
be in oh come on the can't be in Oh did
soup is it just gonna send me exactly
back where I was or is it gonna take me
somewhere new and maybe when I get
somewhere new maybe I could always know
oh that's yeah that's actually just it
but that's so weird
but what's around you is there something
else I didn't exactly go everywhere I
barely got into that fish area if
there's something else hidden here then
maybe I can find it I only got in that
room for you oh hi oh hi fish how you
doing
oh hi goodbye you carry on I'm gonna go
this way cuz I don't know what awaits me
down these roads that's the weird thing
about this game I don't know if it's a
matter of exploration but there's no
objective and a lot of these
experimental games sometimes are lacking
purpose and more about you know
conveying a concept you know not
necessarily giving you an objective but
giving you like an idea and I think
that's what this one is getting across I
mean the world is very weird and I don't
know where I'm walking to but I'm
walking away
okay oh all right I guess I'm not
supposed to go that way but the Sun has
not set just yet I just wandered a
little too far off into the wilderness
Oh
[Music]
what is this I don't think that's how
windmills work
oh you're flying so what are you what
are any of you you're tiny who kissed it
out of existence I kill everything I
kiss my son over you okay
it seemed to be venturing off into the
bright brightness but the Sun doesn't
set I imagine that the Sun doesn't set
until you go in that building and this
might send me reeling back to the
beginning but I don't know where else to
go
besides this way or if there are secrets
in the misty mist Oh Sun is setting Oh
whoosh oh no I'm not ready please I
don't want to go yet girl lady over here
what's the secret of this place what
does it mean why are the birds what were
you reading why are you naked I have so
many questions I have so many questions
and I guess I don't have enough time to
answer them it's a very fleeting
experience like that is that is
absolutely 100% like this game is just
very very fleeting you only get a few
minutes to be able to explore this world
and yet there's a lot of different
directions that you could go
Oh but not a lot of time to get there
and even this is close to me oh come on
now I fight against you I rebelled
against the darkness I didn't rebelled
very hard cos move back here now but
okay don't consume me Oh being scoots
from behind as well but that is
Sacramento it's really cool
I gotta admit that's a really cool short
experience I like that I love that
actually it felt right like you know
when you go into a world and it just
feels weird but it feels natural for
what it is
despite its weirdness it existed in its
own way and the only way it could and I
know that's philosophical [ __ ] and
whatever that means is up to
interpretation but I get it I get it and
that was really cool so thank you
everybody so much for watching if you
want to tell me what you think about
this gamer you want to try it for
yourself and maybe there's a secret in
there to discover or maybe there's no
secrets to discover and it is what it is
either way let me know in the comments
below thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video bye bye